good morning John I have developed an
unhealthy obsession with the word cool
not the concept of cool that's just I
mean it's a lot and I'm clearly not an
expert I mean the word or words that we
use to identify that mutable mix of
simultaneously embodying and defying
culture and defining culture as well if
nothing else cool and it's neighborhood
of words attempt to define that
bleeding-edge of cultures aesthetic an
edge that seems out of everyone's
control precisely because it's
controlled by everyone there are a lot
of these words precisely for that recess
culture changes it needs new words to
embody itself because those old words
are defining an old culture and its
culture changes faster we get more and
more of them now it's widely accepted
that the word with the most synonyms in
English is drunk this was I think first
proposed by Benjamin Franklin and it is
difficult to argue with but mostly
because it's just very hard to measure
slang in any case though I think that
cool could give drunk a run for its
money
dope rad bad off the heezy the bee's
knees on the ball peachy keen slam and
smoke and sweet far out groovy hip legit
boss wizard wicked jokes choice gnarly
the cat's pajamas crack-a-lackin' nifty
fine fab fly fresh fat non flee just to
name a few culture defines the words and
the words define the culture the very
existence of the concept of cool itself
requires a kind of cultural
self-awareness culture needs to know
that culture exists so it can identify
and co-opt words to use to define itself
win I think that culture is aware of
itself in a kind of limited way like
when I look at myself with a mirror
I'm seeing myself on the surface level I
can like do my hair and check for my
pimples but not really getting very deep
when I think about myself though I'm
thinking about my hopes in my fears and
my motivations and the effects that I
have on the world around that's what I'm
thinking about my actual self and that's
a whole other thing culture it feels
like it's kind of often mindlessly
self-aware like it's looking at itself
in the mirror and being quite impressed
with what it sees there but not
examining itself in a deeper way culture
has a hard time being truly self aware
being able to examine itself in its
motivations its effects and its hopes in
its fears it's hard for culture to do
that but one way that we can do it is to
examine the choices that culture makes
and maybe that'll give us some deeper
insight and cool that bleeding edge of
the collective self is a really good
place to look for that insight like in
the 60s with a focus on both space
exploration and drug
her words for cool we're like far out
and out of this world are just gone
surfer culture was more about enthusiasm
than aloofness and spawned words like
mondo and bodacious and radical these
words almost always come to the
mainstream from some kind of subculture
out of rock and roll or punk or beat
poets ugh most commonly they come out of
marginalized cultures the first use of
cool itself to identify the the concept
of coolness was traced back to the 1880s
in african-american English often these
words are co-opted and redefined by the
mainstream in a kind of colonization of
the cool of marginalized cultures that
the mainstream has itself marginalize
diversity creates these opportunities
for cultural advancement but the wave
can also be destructive if we forget
that we're the ones who built it and
don't question its effects ultimately
and thank goodness we get to decide for
ourselves what cool is
we both create and are created by
culture so maybe we have an obligation
to inspect that wave and to see if we
can understand its motivations and its
effect and that is why I have become
obsessed with the word cool John I'll
see you on Tuesday please I want so
badly for there to be productive
discussion in the comments there was a
lot that I couldn't say in this video
because there's just not enough time so
I'll hope a lot of that discussion gets
to happen down in the comments also I'm
going to be performing with welcome to
night Vale in Portland in Seattle on
October 27th and 28th and yes nerdcon
stories is still the thing that's going
to be happening October 9th and 10th in
Minneapolis hosts VidCon we've been
doing a lot of talking and planning
about nerdcon stories and I'm really
excited about we've sold most of the
tickets not all of them okay goodbye